you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I'm going to play a 5-2 game
against berchik all right let's try d4
oh all right I usually play Knight f3
let's welcome a nimzo-indian hora Queen
Queens gambit declined one of the few
times I'm open for Bishop b4 I was going
to play Queen c2 but okay Queens gambit
declined we have now let's get in e3 and
what next
hmm Brooke c1 I could capture I like to
first see b6 before I capture though hmm
let's play Knight f3
so I'm ruling out now any possibility
for a central pawn break alright maybe
now I capture you know let's go with
this capture know at least the bishop is
obstructed if this pawn recaptures okay
I think I got a take and I guess we're
going to take again on d5 some
hesitation there maybe they were
considering Knight takes c3 alright
let's just play it really simple I have
nice bishop with my pawn structure
Bishop d3 yeah sure okay let's go there
a knight f6 I'm going to play Knight
here just to sidestep any pin Queen B
for I'm fine with Queen d2 Queen
exchange my king will be fine on this
square they would probably I think
they're going to challenge my knight
with Knight d7 and or that move huh okay
I think what's going to happen is
they're going to kick my knight and then
after Knight f3 Bishop g4 but I could
claim maybe a little bit of success and
that they weaken their King by playing
f6 I thought maybe c5 was an idea let's
play brook c1 there aren't any tricks
excuse me there aren't any tricks
against my bishop here he's secure um
this Knight is a little bit of a pest
let's go Queen c2 and look to dislodge
this Knight I'm threatening now f3 it's
pretty serious
okay well probably just night here and
I'm looking to yet again challenge this
knight Knight d2 or Knight h4 given some
time I'd like to go forward with the
minority attack seems like they're
ignoring this idea yeah I think that's a
mistake now after Knight h4 let's
consider for a moment that was a very
slow move their last move King in the
corner this is an unprotected piece I
guess after Knight here they do have
Bishop d7 if I take they take with the
pawn a my night is a bit stranded hmm
okay um can i play b4 here queen takes
b4 the knight h4 i don't know about that
Knight d2 is a pretty simple approach
I'd like to mmm you know if we have a
situation where the both minor pieces
are exchanged it's going to be a race to
see who can crack at the pawn structure
right away I'd like to have these guys a
little further advance but that's kind
of tough to get in hmm let me start with
maybe a three and then B form I still
have this in my Knight d2 b4 maybe
Knight H for the knight can't move he's
pinned night here Knight takes bishop
takes they take my rook so I was
considering a rook move but it seems
pretty slow not ready hmm it seems too
slow let's challenge their night
and if they played out five g3i weaken
these light squares but he could help
out with defending hmm they're going
straight in for that how about I first
play h3 actually and then g3 do f3 f4
but then this is a forever this is a
target for forever be different if I
could get a rook on e5 with opponent if
for but how do I ever make that happen
well they're not threatening f4 just yet
let's get on with my minority attack way
down on time a 4 B 5 you know okay it's
now I can play f4 with tempo or maybe
even first f3 mmm let's go with f3 do f4
at some point I need to brake really
soon the Queen side on it for I think I
play here they have the a file but I
have pressure on c6 they take on b5 I
don't know that I even recapture maybe
rook c7 on rook e8 I have this I'm Queen
e7 I think I'll have to play here king
f2 is met with Queen h4 g3 Queen takes
pawn
so King f2 the Queen always puts me in
check it's a very active move can't
though on c6 twice kind of move I don't
know I guess they're gonna have to show
me what I'm missing they still need a
flight square for their King so he has a
certain responsibility excuse me
a certain responsibility of defending
the back ring f-4e for this pawn is
unprotected their rook isn't protected
in fact Queen before his felt frog spot
they could then connect them oh you know
if I like this one right here I was
talking earlier about if I could get a
rook here couldn't quite see how that
would happen in the earlier position but
right here it's a different story
um-hmm let's go with this release the
pressure on e3 go here hmm
what am i doing I got to play Bishop f1
if I play Queen f2 there was a rook
takes Bishop at the end Queen takes
Queen and then rook takes Bishop I'm
really in a giant knot here not quite
sure how I untangle be honest hmm
yikes
their queen is kind of short on squares
though no Queen h4 King h2 what are they
going to play here not sure how they
improve their pieces maybe improvement
is rook to e7 targeting g7 but their
Queen is there to defend get my Queen on
e5 and take on h6 he Ike's my rook is
stuck on f2 my bishops pinned Bishop f3
at some point an idea not so sure about
that
yeah I understand they're struggling to
find a move I'm struggling to even
suggest a move for black but I have a
big time edge they're really in the
think tank here I guess we'll go here
Queen takes f5 hmmm for second
not a lot I have this I also have Queen
here to defend oh they have that move
and then rook checks I'm getting made it
here yepper where is the mate
all right here's me that'll do it
oh yeah I forgot that they could just
take and then enter I don't have time
for that check mmm
where in the world could I have done
better all right well let's go back into
it without the engine
okay so Queens gambit declined this
exchange two minor pieces this is just
an even position but wandering right
around here what I could have done
better maybe this is already a little
bit off it's a half-open file but I
should be more direct with Queen c2 but
maybe even here I miss playing at some
with this Knight to e5 idea because on
castles maybe this is already a
possibility to change the structure I
can't take because I drop my knight and
maybe I have to worry some about c4 one
day where they would have a three versus
two on the Queen side okay so I don't
know if I would really go with rook c1
again I can still shoot for this maybe
even at an early moment like right now
move what is it move thirteen look for a
3 B for the 183 I'm pretty sure there's
going to be a 5
some time to get in be for strick eat
ooh get in before actually the Queen
honor their I'm playing rippy one
there's this clamping down a form of mmm
okay shouldn't be bad this position most
likely just even but I have to come up
with something better here hmm
his f3 necessary I'm not careful there's
this stuff pawn is pinned I think that
this is okay
and do you know what years well I was
going to say here's another reason not
to have played rip to c1 because when I
do cut this b5 move in there rook get
some activity but I don't know I'm up
upon here hmm played rook there and
they're getting doubled on the a file up
upon but this rook on f1 isn't playing
so if we do just some piece comparison
here they have well let's just say these
to offset they're playing with very
activate three rook versus my passive f1
rook so I'm trying to what I'm doing
right here is just trying to show some
where there where there is some
compensation for black very active rook
versus rook that is not yet playing on
f1 and the other factor is the queen
position so maybe that's the biggest
factor Queen on d2 versus a black Queen
on g5 fifth ranked Queen versus a second
ranked Queen they have some pressure
here I should be able to hold this but
yeah it's clearly tricky f4
is that really necessary hmm I'm just
inviting them forward am I not to do
something different here plate f4 and
then h3 and the queen is just entering
closer hmm if I take here there's rook
here
I'd have to play Bishop c2 and that's
very awkward something like this if I
move my queen I made it on g2 if I go
here there's rook c8 mm this really
isn't a good idea I don't think maybe I
could hold on but he had to work
yourself into a pin like this probably
not a good idea but I shouldn't have
invited the Queen into my position like
this I mean h3 Queen here yeah you know
I was thinking I could play Queen f2 to
dislodge the Queen but I forgot I'd be
dropping the bishop this is what I
wanted to do but I lose a piece so
that's no good
so I should do without h3 for sure
they're very active this rook you know
what I was saying that these to offset
I'm not sure I really like my rook here
hmm he's defending this pawn but as far
as aggressive ideas for the rook he
isn't really doing anything like this
rook could always leave the back rank
when even if the bishop let's just say
wasn't on this guarding the square even
if I am to get to the back rank they
could always step up this is only one
attacking piece so it's really of no
bother to black Queen g3 so right around
here I don't know not sure what I should
have done different right around here
I'm up upon but it's tricky hmm no no
what am I missing
yeah maybe it's now just busted because
of this idea of taking twice here and
then entering on a1 yeah they sprint
quite some time on this seems like a
pretty good idea
we should EA to there
maybe I have to stop Bishop to b5 like
Queen to b4 or maybe even Queen B - at
least I'm threatening rook takes Bishop
and then take here
I'm also stopping Bishop b5 this is
defended maybe maybe I need to play
Queen B - here okay well I ended up just
getting made it here with that capture
on f1 alright let's see what the
computer is saying for this one put the
arrows on board and see where we could
improve okay it's just a even ish
position doesn't like rook c1 it does
like Queen c2 okay now Queen c2 Knight
h4 yeah let's mentioned I didn't like
this idea if I am going in for this
capture and my Knights stranded it
doesn't suggest Bishop takes Knight but
hmm it's kind of a weird follow-up you
play here kick the bishop back and now
Rick - e1 is the follow-up I don't know
about that
okay yeah tight game rook e1 I got on
with b4 f3 I break they enter and so
they shouldn't allow this capture on c6
but mm-hmm
it's calling for a defense of c6 take
double it's fine at that for Bishop b1
mmm that is an interesting move yeah I'm
going to remember a move like that now
that stabilizes my queen position it
stops your up to a two and I could now
consider h3 and queen of two also worth
noting is that this Queen is pretty
short on squares so I think in just a
couple moves I'm really close to forcing
a queen exchange
it's a tough move Fischer to be one but
it stops the rooks from getting active
can't get to the second and if you get
to the a file or the a1 square the first
rank not sure what that's really doing
okay one its Queen c2 looking to pick
off the f5 pawn okay to not consider
that and yeah as mentioned if I'd go
here now I'm working myself into a pin
it's not fun I'm up to pawns here and
it's about an even position so yeah you
don't really go in for this kind of
stuff look at this how many pins are
they taking advantage of let me show
that line once more takes rook here
Bishop c2 taking advantage of this pin
taking advantage of this pin I have to
do stuff like that Wow
yeah so you really don't go in for that
stuff I played rook F to mmm and I guess
they already have a shot
with rook takes Bishop and then a check
oh wow oh you have to block with the
Queen now that's interesting so this is
a tactic that we both missed here after
rook F to the very moment that my king
is more vulnerable on this first rank
they could already go in for this nice
shot
check I've locked with the rook I'm
getting mated he's out of play hm
I'd have to pitch the Queen cool shot
rook takes Bishop right now as soon as I
play Rock f2 rook check bishop f1 the
game continues invested a lot of time on
bishop there I played Queen c2 and now
it's just busted yeah it was I hope that
a five pawn even I pointed out Queen B -
which is fine but you know it's tough
but a pawn but they have really good
pieces and I need to play a little bit
better here defensively tactic we both
missed there on d3 and then this final
one here just taking and then a quick
little King Hunt okay as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below and I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you